popular sites across las vegas are  covered in purple today for  crime victims rights week this year  there is a special emphasis on marsy's  law  that was passed by voters in 2018 to  ensure crime victims and their families  have information about their cases  it's named for marcy nicholas who was  murdered by her ex-boyfriend in  california in the 1980s  here in nevada advocates are helping  keep victims safe and in the loop with  updates on cases which involve them  if we didn't have these rules in the  body of the constitution for the state  of nevada  there was always a possibility that they  didn't have to be recognized  and so with this recognition now in the  constitution  it solidifies those rights for victims  nevada is one of 10 states that have  passed  some form of marsy's law